was the equivalent
yeah it's great
okay guys
[Music]
okay ten seconds this are going
[Music]
in yesterday's plane crash in Iran yeah
agent as the victims and their families
and of the communities who are mourning
those losses what happened yesterday is
a tragedy that it not only shocked
Canada it shocked the entire world
before continuing I would once again
like to offer my most sincere
condolences to the families and loved
ones who are grieving we all stand with
you what happened yesterday was a
tragedy a tragedy that shocked and only
keep not only Canada but the world
before we go any further I want to
extend once again my most sincere
condolences to the families of the
victims and their loved ones I and we
are all standing with you
since last addressing Canadians there
have been ongoing discussions since I
last addressed Canadians there have been
ongoing discussions with foreign
ministers senior intelligence and
military officials including the fourth
meeting of our Incident Response Group
there have been important developments
regarding the potential causes of this
deadly crash developments of which
Canadians should be made aware the news
will undoubtedly come as a further shock
to the families who are already grieving
in the face of this unspeakable tragedy
we have intelligence from multiple
sources including our allies and our own
intelligence the evidence indicates that
the plane was shot down by an Iranian
surface-to-air missile this may well
have been unintentional this new
information reinforces the need for a
thorough investigation into this matter
Canada is working with its allies to
ensure that a thorough and credible
investigation is conducted to determine
the causes of this fatal crash as I said
yesterday Canadians have questions and
they deserve answers day one dlc allow
me to repeat what I just said
intelligence from various plane was
brought down by a surface-to-air missile
from Iran it is possible that this was
inadvertent this news confirms the need
to have an in-depth investigation into
this affair yeah as I said yesterday
you'll Canadians have questions and they
deserve answers
Canada is working with its allies to
ensure that an in-depth investigation is
conducted so that we can uncover the
causes of this tragic
foreign minister faso egypt shopping
spoke with Iranian Foreign Minister
Zarif Minister Xiao Fang made it clear
the Canadian officials must immediately
be granted access to Iran in order to
provide consular services identify the
victims
and participate in a thorough
investigation he also condemned Iranian
strikes the targeted military bases
interests where coalition forces
including Canadians are currently
stationed ministers Minister Zarif
committed to continuing this dialogue
with Canada as we seek answers
I spoke with ukrainian President
Vladimir szalinski earlier today and
conveyed my condolences to the many
Ukrainians who perished in this tragedy
he assured me that Ukraine is taking all
necessary measures to ensure the
thorough investigation we will work
closely with Ukraine and our partners
throughout this process I also called
Prime Minister Mark Rutte day of the
Netherlands he shared with me his
experience in handling the aftermath and
investigation into Malaysian Airlines
flight 17 sure mister you got him on
foot new victories not very difficult
I'm also in contact with a number of
other international leaders and those
discussions are ongoing we'll continue
to work closely with our partners in the
coming days information it is now more
important than ever that we know exactly
how such a tragedy could have happened
the families of the victims and all
Canadians want
any accountability and justice and this
government will not rest until we get
that thank you for being here this
morning I'll now take your questions so
first question
Ellen Buzzelli and then we'll go to
Glenn McGregor CTV what response Iran
gave you are they accepting we're
working with Ukrainian investigators at
this time and we are continuing to have
Canadians involved in this process
given the context do you feel that the
u.s. is partly responsible for this
given that they created the situation in
which the missiles were launched I think
that's one of the many questions that
people will be thinking about and try
and find answers to for the moment I
just want to underline the importance of
having a full and credible investigation
so that we can get those facts and then
we can continue to analyze based on
those facts and can underscores how
important it is that we have a thorough
credible investigation to allow us to
then draw conclusions and reflections
once we have assessed and established
the facts of what happened mr. could you
describe in some more detail the kind of
information you have that indicates that
this was a surface-to-air strike as you
know an extremely serious allegation and
Canadians are gonna want to see proof
that this is what happened but the
intelligence and evidence suggests that
it is likely that it was a
surface-to-air strike but I will not go
into the details of that and
at this time given that the Iranians
have denied this and there's reports
they're bulldozing the crash site
they've claimed the flight and voice and
data recorders have been damaged do you
trust them that they haven't actually
already compromised the investigation at
this point do you think it's a
possibility that that we won't get a
real answer we highlighted that it is
extremely important that there be a
thorough and credible investigation on
site understanding that with the
conclusions we have been able to draw on
the or the preliminary conclusions we've
been able to draw based on intelligence
and evidence today are clear enough for
me to share them with Canadians right
now so next up Catherine okay they will
be keeping the black boxes in Iran they
told a Ukrainian president Solinsky the
Ukrainian investigators at least would
have access to the black boxes the
Iranian authorities have indicated that
they wish to keep the black boxes in
Iran but have indicated to president
zalenski of Ukraine that Ukrainian
investigators would have access to those
black boxes you come up with a fool how
can you trust when they're denying some
of the information that you just shared
with us we recognize that this is a
situation where we're going to need to
get more clarity more answers and that's
why we are calling for a complete and
credible investigation with
international partners so that we can
uncover the facts of what happened for
Canadians for the families affected and
for people around the world hi Prime
Minister I just want to circle back to
an earlier question if the intelligence
is accurate then it seems this is the
end result
of a sequence of events that was sparked
by the drone strike ordered by the US
president so given the information you
have how much responsibility does the
United States bear for this tragedy the
evidence suggests that this is the
likely cause but we need to have a full
and complete and credible investigation
to establish exactly what happened that
is what we are calling for and that is
what we are expecting will happen if
Iran does not cooperate and there are
some reports of at least minimal
cooperation or questionable cooperation
to this point what pressure can you
bring to bear would you argue for
sanctions would economic repercussions
what can Candida do to pressure Iran to
give you the investigation you want I
think those are our conversations and
steps we will contemplate as things move
forward if it doesn't appear that there
is a credible complete investigation but
right now we continue to work with
partners and and direct Iran with our
requests that we have a credible and
complete investigation okay gonna go to
Marie vostell next and then afterwards
David Aitken
oh okay
yeah huh back to the question now my
spear around if you're concluding that
this is due to a missile strike
what will your reaction be and how do
you intend to respond to arrest well
first of all it was based on a
preliminary analysis of the intelligence
that we have it just underscores the
importance of having a credible and
complete investigation into exactly what
happened that's why we're going to draw
any other conclusions to our forces in
Iraq remain the same or will something
change I imagine something well indeed
this is a very concerning situation
that's why we want to know more we're
going to be working with international
authorities and with investigators and
with Iran in order to get answers into
exactly what happened we recognize that
this may have been done accidentally but
that just makes it even more important
to clarify exactly what happened Reagan
and then we'll go down to a crostini one
left
good afternoon Prime Minister I just
want to come back to the qualifiers
you've been using may well had been
unintentional been accidental that
implies that it may not have been
unintentional can you be as definitive
as you can be knowing what you know
knowing what you can't share with us
about the intentionality of this
apparent missile strike I think that is
one of the reasons why it is so
important to have a full and credible
investigation before we get into
definitive conclusions as you say we
need to ensure that we have all the
facts gathered the intelligence and
evidence right now suggests very clearly
a possible and probable cause for the
crash but it is all the more necessary
therefore to gather all the evidence to
have a complete picture of what happened
and let's follow through then that the
evidence does in fact show that it was
an accidental unintentional
surface-to-air missile what range of
options would the the government would
the Government of Canada respond in some
way to that and if so what range of
responses might your government consider
I think anything in the range of
responses would need to start from a
clearer understanding and a credible
confirmation of what actually happened
and that is why a proper and full
investigation is going to be so
important because you know and then
we'll go next to Michelle Ponce is my
main concern about this was a missile
and it was a unintentional well to be
convinced to beyond all doubt we would
need a credible thorough and in-depth
investigation and that is exactly what
we're calling for it we want a complete
investigation that's what we asked for
yesterday and we're continuing to ask
for that today those discussions are
ongoing
and I want to tell Canadians and
families that what we have gathered in
terms of intelligence does indicate very
clearly that this could very well have
been an unintentional surface to missile
leaf a surface-to-air missile strike and
for the families of the victims do you
want answers how can you reassure
Canadians really doing everything a well
possible to get answers and to keep to
have a credible transparent
investigation well we understand that
investigations at this time this type do
take time we know that getting really
thorough investigation takes time this
is only the second day and we're only
drawing preliminary conclusions at this
time we do need more clarity for the
Canadians and the families who are
feeling despair and who are really
suffering right now so we will continue
to insist on getting more information
and more in-depth investigation right
hi Prime Minister when you spoke with
President zolensky today had he been
briefed by any of his out any allies on
this intelligence that you've been
receiving in the in the recent hours or
did you have to show this intelligence
with him for the first time I shared
with him some of the reasons we are so
intent on having a full and complete
investigation we know that is extremely
important to establish clarity around
the facts of what happened and he
assured me that Canada as
friend of Ukraine will be closely
involved with them in the investigation
into this tragedy it's already been used
to hit the plane I believe there have
been media reports about it for much of
the day but I don't know for sure
whether he was briefed by intelligence
officials or not it's gonna go to the
back of the room this was intentional
correct it's really too early to draw
any clear conclusions or to rule out any
other possibilities certainly we know
that we need more in-depth and credible
investigation that we'll be able to
establish beyond any doubt what the
causes of this tragic accident was a
veto some discussions with other
counterparts have you tried to talk to
your counterparts I'm not to talk to
anyone in order to get answers in this
tragedy
given the tensions in the area that were
the cause of a drone strike by the
United States do you think that the
United States is at least partially
responsible for this tragedy I think it
is too soon to be drawing conclusions or
assigning blame or responsibility and
whatever proportions right now our focus
is on supporting the families that are
grieving right across the country and
providing what answers we can in a
preliminary way but recognizing there is
going to need to be a full and credible
investigation into what exactly happened
before we draw any conclusions earlier
today President Trump characterized well
said he had concerns that a missile
might have brought down the plane and he
said it was a it's a very rough
neighborhood I was wondering what you
thought of that characterization I'll
let mr. Trump's words stand for
themselves I'm gonna go back to Ryan the
National Post Prime Minister we don't
have a diplomatic relationships with
Iran the country is already heavily
sanctioned by the international
community
are you worried in terms of trying to
get good behavior like access to the
site and participation in the
investigation the candidate doesn't have
any levers here that we don't have any
list truths words at this moment and the
Iranian authorities have have indicated
that they would be open to issuing visas
so that consular
assistance can be given on the ground in
the there are consular officials who
were on their way to Turkey and Iran has
indicated that they would be open to
issuing visas so that those people would
be able to come to the site for family
talk with the Iranian Foreign Minister
did was he open to allowing Canadians to
be part of the investigation because
their Air Transport Authority says that
we have been invited to be part of the
investigation there has been openness to
Canadian involvement in the
investigation from the beginning
expressed by the Iranians but Minister
Shaun pang will be holding a press
conference in a few hours where he can
answer those questions in more detail
I'm gonna go to Maura Forrest mr. just
on that same question can you be a
little more specific how confident are
you that Canadian officials will be
involved in this investigation
Canadian expertise when it comes to air
air tragedies to expertise when it comes
to craft invested crash investigation is
world-class we have much to contribute
and we have lost much in the loss of so
many Canadian lives so many families
across this country
grieving we will be involved we will
offer all the expertise that we have to
offer we have already been engaged with
the Ukrainians who are part of the
investigation team and Iran has
indicated an openness to Canada being
engaged as well to what degree and what
way remains to be worked out but there
is an openness there and I just wonder
what you think Canadian families of the
victims must be feeling now knowing that
there is a good possibility that their
loved ones have been caught up in this
dispute between the u.s. and Iran as I
said it is unimaginable what these
families are going through right now in
terms of grieving just for having lost
loved ones I know from
conversations that have been had with
government officials with members of
parliament with my Deputy Prime Minister
who's been engaged with families in
Edmonton that families are asking for it
is now but there are many more answers
to be given there there is much more to
be found out through a complete and
thorough investigation that we are
certainly pushing for but we know these
families will continue to be going
through extremely difficult moments over
the coming hours days weeks months and
indeed years and Canada will be there
with them liebherr through
yes sir I'm just wondering do you regret
not pushing harder to restart diplomatic
relations with Iran as you had promised
in the 2015 election I think there are
many reasons why Canada has significant
issues with Iran and asked for a number
of years but in this situation it is
clear that we are coming together in the
wake of a terrible tragedy that's
befallen Canadians it has befallen many
Iranian citizens as well and can't
forget that the majority of victims on
that airline were Iranian citizens and
this is something that binds us together
in our grief and I think the desire for
answers from families who lost loved
ones is fairly universal we will be
working together and the best ways that
we can around this tragedy and you
mentioned that you had spoken to Prime
Minister root a can you talk about what
advice he gave you given their
experience he talked a lot about how it
is first of all important to keep the
families who are grieving apprised of
information even at preliminary stages
which is certainly something that we are
we are doing today he also talked about
the need for direct and real
relationships with all different
elements involved in the crash he talked
about the fact that he had multiple
conversations with Russian authorities
including Vladimir Putin in the days
following the Malaysian Airlines down so
we certainly have taken taken those and
other elements seriously their path
through an international investigation
that continues even five years later was
one that he shared with me and he of
course offered the deep friendship that
the Dutch have with Canada to to serve
to share expertise and information and
support as we embark upon what is going
to be a difficult process of establish a
path through an international after
prime minister just wondering if the
government considers this an act of war
I think it is too early to draw
definitive conclusions like that one
that is why we need a complete and
credible investigation and can you just
walk us through when you became aware of
these most recent allegations involving
the aircraft and also going forward what
Canada's response like are you gonna
speak to the leadership of Iran yourself
to convey Canada's views on this and
should it be an international commission
for an investigation we got confirmation
over the course of last night and this
morning on this particular set of
conclusions that I've shared today but
obviously there is much more work to be
done much more data to be analyzed and
that's why the incredible investigation
is so important I think there is a call
and there are in incidents of tragic
Craster's crashes like this ones
multiple parties who are mandated to be
involved from manufacturers of the
airplane and we
France being and the engines of the
airplane being manufactured in France
that gives say a certain Authority for
the French to be involved as part of the
international investigation process
family countries that have victims on
the plane also have standing in an
investigation Canada of course is the
country outside of Iran that has lost
the most citizens the country of
operation and ownership of the aircraft
is also responsible and that has a
responsibility in the investigation and
that involves Ukraine there are many
different international elements in a
and investigation of this type and that
is what we will be drawing on as we move
forward so one from rosemary Barton and
then we'll go to John Iverson Prime
Minister obviously you suspected you
feared the worst when you were asked
whether you could rule out that this had
happened it may have been confirmed
overnight but you obviously had your own
concerns can you just talk a little bit
about what your reaction was when it was
confirmed were you outraged just explain
to me what went through your head
knowing that did you you fear the worst
and getting to know over these past 24
hours through news articles and and
reports back from various conversations
I've had with MPs with government
officials they are already going through
a terrible terrible grieving process and
to further
and understanding that this may have
been caused by a surface-to-air missile
strike is is compounding and that my
thoughts instantly went to how much
harder this must make it for those
families who are experiencing just a
terrible amount of grief right now my
first thoughts were for the families
we're already suffering terribly after
losing their loved ones but knowing that
there may have been additional aspect
the missile strike only makes things
harder for them so we will be there for
them in this difficult time if it turns
out to be a missile strike
Canada's options would seem to be pretty
limited the Magnitsky act a tool that
could be used against individuals who
are deemed to be responsible I think it
is too early to draw conclusions on what
tools could eventually be used depending
on the final assessment or final
conclusions of a complete investigation
our focus right now is on giving
immediate support to the families
working with them to to ensure that the
remains of their loved ones has brought
home to Canada if that is their wishes
and indeed move forward on a full and
complete investigation so that we can
then look at next steps in the healing
accountability justice process these are
things that will come in due course but
right now we are standing firmly and
entirely with the families yes thank you
very much
Missy to
well I think that NATO should be
expanded and we should include the
Middle East having an international
flavor there is good and I actually had
a name
NATO right and then you have M II Middle
East
yo chord they told me I said what a
beautiful name think of the song YMCA
now everybody says it they don't
remember the previous name of a bad deal
okay
commonly known as NAFTA now if you add
the words if you add the two words but
at least at the